- [Narrator] At first glance,
visitors may not realize
that inside this mosque
is a multi-colored secret.
(ethereal music)
Located in Iran, the Nasir al-Mulk mosque
is commonly known as The Pink Mosque,
due to the rose colored tiles
that cover the interior,
however, this is far from
the only color found inside.
A wall of stained glass
windows turns the interior
into a rainbow wonderland.
Built in 1888, the mosque
took 12 years to complete.
Nasir al-Mulk features
plenty of traditional
Islamic architecture elements,
such as the arches and
the central structure,
however, the presence of
stained glass windows,
a design element relatively
rare for mosques,
makes this particular mosque
a unique and stunning sight to see.
The stained glass in
Nasir al-Mulk was built
to catch the morning sunlight
as it reflects off the walls
and the brightly colored
Persian rugs on the floor.
The hope and intention was
for the colors to create
a peaceful atmosphere
during early morning prayer.
The Nasir al-Mulk mosque has
become as much of a destination
for visitors seeking the perfect photo
as those who still worship
under the rainbow of light.